hi I'm Sasha I'm going to tell you thank
you for sticking with me through that
appreciate it let's start out let me
tell you a data story and it's a data
horror story actually this happened to a
client of mine they were an e-commerce
company that had a very interesting data
set they hired us to take a look at it
and the VP we were working with had a
great idea he was like hey we're an
e-commerce company it's November the
holidays are coming up
let's do a story that compares the
shopping season last year to the
shopping season this year and put out a
piece the press will love it we'll get
all sorts of new customers and we were
like that sounds great and then we
looked at their data set and they had a
problem that their engineers knew about
and fixed in April but their data before
April was not really usable so we had to
go to the GP and say no you can't do
this great press story because you lost
the first eight months of your company's
data it's unusable and he was like so
this is a data horror story don't let
this happen to you that's what this
whole talk today is about it's about
preventing horrible data problems down
the road for yourself and this talk is
really for people who like starting
things people who like starting
companies or products or even adding
features to existing products or just
don't even have a data science team yet
and haven't done this sort of thing and
you might be like hard to sleep at night
because you don't know if your data set
has these sorts of problems and these
sorts of horror stories keep you up and
so hi I'm Sasha I also like starting
things two things that I've been either
started or early at are you may have
heard of our code Academy I was an early
hire there back when they had one lesson
on the site I also started a group
called women new code that has 15,000
women developers across the world so I
really like being there in that early
stage of things when it's super chaotic
and your to-do list is so long you don't
know where to start you just have to put
it in order it start at the top and so
we've worked now I work and I'm having
start poly numeral which is a applied
data strategy consultancy here in New
York and one thing we do is we work with
a lot of different sorts of
organizations we work with tiny
nonprofits we work with startups we work
with big established companies we work
with NGOs halfway across the world and
we help them be more strategic with
their data and do new and interesting
things and so we've seen a lot of
different data sets and a lot of
different constraints
and we've worked with a lot of great
super solid engineering teams who were
pushing out super interesting products
and doing their best on this logging
thing and still made mistakes that bit
them later and we've actually had a few
of these mistakes slip by us when we
added their data so we've been like
iterating each time we do this to make
sure we catch more and more these
mistakes and I want to share the last
year of this with you guys today with
some more stories that unfortunately I
have to fuzz a little bit to protect our
clients so I am gonna be a little vague
in some of these stories
so today the talk is gonna cover is your
data set complete is it correct and is
it connected and these are three things
that you can go off and check take a few
days to check now and put your mind at
ease the rest of the talk is gonna be
expand on these three things
but before we talk about that why bother
why bother doing this how can you
justify to yourself and your long to-do
list and your boss and all your
stakeholders why it makes sense to do
these things now I mean aren't data
scientists wizards well yes but no
algorithms are useless if you don't have
any data no matter how smart a data
scientist you hire later they can't do
anything if they don't have a good data
set to work with if it is missing or
it's wrong and you can't trust it like
it's very hard for them to do good work
so if you get your ducks in a row now
you're setting yourself up to do really
interesting things down the road so
let's look at the another exercise that
I like you all to do right now is think
of a project or company like pick one in
your life that you're thinking about
applying this stuff to and think about
what is critical so what are your
business needs for this project and I
don't mean business literally it doesn't
have to be a company or something that
even has money associated with it and if
you're at a loss is a project to think
about pick a website you spend a lot of
time on like reddit or Packer Newser or
the New York Times or whatever business
needs really mean what moves the needle
what actually makes a difference what
gets you more users what gets you more
revenue what cuts down on your bounce
rate what gets your app more downloads
whatever that success metric is to you
take a second right now and think about
what actually would move the needle for
you what matters and I would need you to
keep that in mind for the next part
okay by the way this is really hard
and if you're sort of struggling with
this I know some great data scientists
you can call and ask for help
I know I'm being somewhat facetious but
my my coworker literally wrote a book on
this it came out by O'Reilly in February
it's a great book it's a very quick read
I highly recommend it especially if
you're just getting started in data
science so keep this question in mind
what is critical what matters okay and
let's go through the first of these
three things is your data set complete
so what this really means is our
business critical fields okay this is
this is one of a few things you can
check so let me tell you another story
we had one client that asked an
interesting question they have a very
popular and beloved widget that's all
over the internet and they refer a lot
of traffic to all these various sites
they don't refer as much as Twitter and
Facebook and those sorts of giants but
they had a hunch that their traffic was
more engaged that it was better quality
traffic they'd be more likely to comment
and stick around longer and
click-through pages and all these sorts
of things so the quality of the traffic
they suspected was higher and they asked
us to check that for them they were
currently logging refers so we didn't
actually know where people were coming
from so we had them log a URL that looks
something like this and so we could see
whether the refer was our client or
someone else however they truncated that
piece of the URL so we didn't know where
they came from
so they were tracking this URL and
everything was great except the one
thing we really needed to do the
analysis was gone
luckily we caught this very quickly
because we knew it's so critical for our
work and we got them to fix it but make
sure the business critical fields that
you really need to do the work that
matters are actually there those are the
first things you should start with one
other thing you can do is check to see
the overall volume is right and you guys
are not going to believe me that you
need to do this but you really do for
example check against other pieces of
knowledge you have like let's say Google
Analytics let's say you're running an
awesome project and your Google
Analytics says you have 500,000 people
coming to your site per month
congratulations first of all that's
awesome but what if your logs only have
5,000
unique users per month in them you're
missing 99% of your data this actually
happened to one of our clients like this
is real I'm not making this I mean I'm
fudging the numbers a little bit to make
the math easier but like they were
literally missing ninety-nine percent of
their unique users so check this I know
I know you don't think you have to but
just make sure the volume of people you
see in your logs is actually lining up
with what you expect through other
sources of information one other sort of
mind shift you might have to make if
you're mostly a software engineer is to
not just log errors if you're getting a
product that been running you want to
log the errors that are happening in
your software so you can go track them
down and fix them right but blogging all
sorts of interesting and useful main
functions that people do on your site
can actually give you a lot of insight
and of course the core layer of this is
take extra good care of this data and
keep it safe because people are really
trusting you with that and so if you're
gonna log a lot of actions on the site
that gives away a lot of information
about people so take good care of it but
here's another example this one of our
clients is a large media company that
has articles and email newsletters and
audio content and video content and a
place where you can donate write a
transactional one and they wanted to see
if they could predict who would donate
more based on their activity on the site
which makes sense right if you're more
interested and you come back every day
and read their stuff like eight hours a
day you might be more likely to donate
than someone who comes once a month and
then leaves but they're only logging two
of these things they're only logging the
donations and the newsletter stuff and
the only reason they were logging the
newsletter stuff is because MailChimp
has like pretty robust data and does
this stuff for you so that is a problem
for our analysis so we had them track
these sorts of things so we could see
who is viewing what and get a better
sense of their activity over time and so
make sure that you are not just logging
errors but you are logging important and
meaningful activities that people do in
your site and if you're thinking this
sounds like a lot to log it is but
storage is so cheap right now it's so
cheap and it just keeps getting cheaper
I bought a 1 terabyte hard drive on
Amazon for $50 and it's about this big
so storage just keeps getting cheaper if
you price it out you'll find that it's
really not that much
so is your data set complete make sure
to check those things now let's talk
about if it is correct this is another
place where you can check your your data
set against existing knowledge so for
example one of our clients had a product
that's like fairly gender neutral but
probably skews a little bit male so they
were like maybe we have 50 to 60 percent
male users and this was relevant to the
project that we were doing and so let's
check it out you guys can come along
with us in a case study where we check
to see that this knowledge existing
knowledge about their users is accurate
and so one of my favorite tools for
doing this is actually the terminal in
order to do more heavy duty analysis you
need something like a dupe or spark or
whatever but to just see if the data
lines up with what you expect him to do
a quick audit of it the terminal is
pretty much the best tool you can use
it's quick you can use all sorts of
really robust tools you can make your
own tools and package them up we'll talk
about that in a minute you can chain
things together so you can get you can
really quickly slice and dice the data
it's it's really awesome I this is a
really important skill that I use all
the time and there's a book that just
came out about it called data science at
the command-line I highly recommend it
it's great I took a look through it it
uses a lot of the tips and tricks that
we it probably numeral use every day and
if there is one thing you take away from
this talk if you were asleep through the
rest of it wake up and write this down
CSV kid is the number one tool I use all
the time it's amazing it just keeps
getting better and it's Python I almost
made that blank but then I decided not
that would be too much so CSV kit it's
written in Python the code is all up on
github it's pretty nice and clean and
concise and it has a ton of different
pieces in it there's into CSV which lets
you connect Excel files to CSV you can
write sequel queries that query or CSV
because sometimes you just really got a
sequel there's CSV JSON CSV looks easy
you grab we're gonna use CSV cut right
now but there's a ton more this is like
a third of what they haven't CSV kid so
let's look at an example and I totally
made these numbers up obviously and so
I'm assuming you all familiar with the
bash prompt the dollar sign where you
type commands after it cat just prints
out logs dot CSV here and so we can see
logs that CSV here
let's see forgive me if you won't click
for me let's see if you can laser point
so we've got a header row here where
you've got the user ID the name of the
person their gender that we've logged
and notice we have a blank one here
we're not sure about that one
and then a join date okay so right now
we're printing it to the screen but we
can also pass it into a new command so
let's pass with the pipe here let's pass
the output of printing the logs into CSV
cut minus n and that prints out the
names of the columns so you saw here
those UID name gender join date it
prints them out here and numbers them
for us and so number three is the one
who are really interested in gender so
let's change our minus n option to a
minus c3 so give me the third column C
is for column and so it just prints out
all the values and since my CSV is only
four lines long I have four things here
if you had a long CSV you would have a
lot of things and so we've got gender
which is again that just that string
that's in the header realm and then MF
and empty string and I put the quotes
there so that you can see it on the
screen now let's do something else with
it so we've got printed our logs we have
taken the third column now let's pass it
into sort which basically puts them in
alphabetical order so we're gonna group
all the MS together all the FS together
all the empty strings together and that
one gender string goes wherever it goes
and then unique them so you're
compressing all the ends together
compressing all the apps together and
then counting how many of them there are
that's what the minus C option does so
this is our output we've got about six
hundred women about six thousand men one
gender header entry and a bunch that are
blank for some reason so what do you
guys think what do you trust this field
no this is about ninety percent male
remember what we thought it was supposed
to be like fifty-five sixty maybe right
so there's something wrong with this
field and it turns out there's a long
time in their products history when they
didn't know the gender of the user and
so they just wrote down em and they
caught this a little bit later and fixed
it but there's a long period of time
where you just cannot trust this data
and the problem is that all the users
they acquired during that
I'm don't have this field it's not
reliable it's not accurate so this is
problematic so check these sorts of
things just make sure you're right just
just check them just check them now even
if you're totally positive and by the
way the one cool really cool thing about
this command-line approach is that you
can actually make your own you can make
your own command-line interface modules
the book I mentioned before and I'll
send you guys a link to it afterwards
the book has a very detailed chapter you
can take Python stuff you can take our
stuff and you can like package it up and
use it in this chained command-line
fashion so quickly look through your
data so it's super super handy so you
have checked that your data is correct
what next
let's take a look and see if it's
connectable so is your data set
connectable what I mean by this is can
you actually join it and just in case
people don't know to join is I'm just
gonna go over it very quickly let's say
you have some census income data so you
have over here you have zip codes and
then you have the median income in that
zip code and again I totally made at
these numbers please don't call me on
any of these you could also have a list
of 3-1-1 calls and for those of you who
are from out of town three one one is
the way you report problems in your area
if you have no heat if you have rats
which is like a constant thing in New
York noise complaints they're looking
through these codes is actually very
funny I highly recommend it there are
some entries in this fight and this file
you can get online where I just want to
be on that call and like hear what the
person answering the call heard because
what they wrote down makes no sense
so anyway check this out it's a very
funny dataset so with this data set you
can answer questions like what's the
richest zip code with this one you can
answer questions like where are the most
complaints but if you were to combine
them together you could answer questions
like do rich people complain more than
poor people or something like that you
could combine these two datasets or do
poor people more things to complain
about than rich people which i think is
a more plausible explanation and so what
we want to do is we want we want to
smush these these two tables together
and we don't just want to glue them
together we want to do it intelligently
so we want to find the places where they
line up so we have one one 201 here and
one one 201 there
and so we want to find them all and like
put them all on the same line together
and so that's called a join and our
joint table will look something like
this so we've got that one zip code
we're interested in here we pulled its
median income and we pulled the
complaints that the person was
complaining about and so we have a long
table of all these together this allows
you to ask much more interesting
questions and to be totally honest if
you don't do this in your data sets in
your work you're gonna have a lot of
doors are gonna be closed to you there's
a lot of super interesting work that you
just can't do and so how can you find
out if your data can join actually do it
like do the join like take a big enough
sample that you'll get a meaningful
number of join things out of it and do
it I've done this before expecting it to
give me like 400 million like joined
entries and it gave me zero or ten ten
was the weird one actually do this join
and check to make sure that it works
like spending that you know an out maybe
an hour doing it would really save you a
lot of time and then check that join
table against your existing knowledge
just like we talked about before one way
to get a quick look at your existing
knowledge and what's in your data set is
histograms and I have a very handy
little tool for you that will give you
an histogram of your data very quickly
it is called data hacks it's put out by
bitly it's on github and I'll put out a
link to this later too and what you do
is you basically output your you slice
and dice your data with CSV kit like
before and then you pipe it into a bunch
of these functions and the one there are
five or six in data hacks and I'm going
to show you histogram dot pie which is
the one I use most and so here's an
example I just took this straight from
their github page you print out your
data file into histogram pie and then it
does a bunch of stats up here which is
really handy so it tells you first of
all how many things are are which you
probably already know but it tells you
the max in the min so you might find
some like really wacky numbers in there
they weren't expecting to see this might
tell you more the mean the variance
standard deviation and then it prints
out an actual histogram it generates it
for you so what this is saying is that
there is one thing with a value between
1 and 1.9 there are five things with a
value between 1.9 and 2.8 and so on and
so forth
so look at the shape of this right here
we can get a sense of the distribution
of our data most of the things are sort
of clustered around three here right and
we don't have much of a longtail because
the max is ten so this gives you a
really quick snapshot of your data
quickly and easily it's a great set of
tools there are a few other ones that
you might have liked there as well and
so use it to check to make sure that you
can join how am i doing on time awesome
thank you okay so here are a few ways
we've seen people have trouble with this
and again I want to stress that these
are very competent engineering teams who
are doing amazing work and this is
something that's like really hard to get
right one of them didn't have joinable
IDs so they were tracking transactions
on one hand and they had a transaction
ID and they were tracking clicks around
on their website and they had a user ID
and they didn't overlap there was no way
to join those two tables together so
they had really rich data but we
couldn't do very much interesting stuff
with it until they added a key that we
could join on to both sets which was
again took maybe an hour to fix and
deploy and tasks but like really
critical that you check that this is
there another one which is a more
interesting case is that they didn't
have unique IDs at all they didn't work
each user in their system didn't have
unique ID and that's because this wasn't
a tech company and they're getting their
data from a wide distributed set of data
sources that were sort of federated but
they didn't have any direct authority
over them and this is actually a more
common scenario than you might think
outside the tech world and and we're
still sort of trying to find the best
way to handle this this situation
because they can't force any of their
data sources to assign a user ID making
sure it's unique across all the data
sources would be very challenging so
it's it's possible but it's expensive
both politically and timewise and so
what we're looking into doing instead is
doing some sort of matching on name last
name and birthdate and sort of manually
cleaning up the ones that don't cleanly
match so this is another another unique
situation if you're thinking yourself
like how hard could this possibly be you
just make a new table and you're [ __ ]
or whatever like there are actually
legit reasons why this is this is hard
to do so make sure that your data set is
connectable so today we've talked about
is your dataset complete is
correct and is it connected and hope you
hope Feliz to start in digging into your
own data today here's a protip
especially if you're thinking to
yourself like huh my boss is not gonna
go for this but it seems important write
down everything you do and actually do
that anyway even if you don't have a
boss or you're if you are the boss or
whatever write down all the things you
check and write down all the things you
find and you fixed and even if you check
and your data set and you're logging
seems great and fine and perfect you
still have a record of what you're
confident in which is important and you
can pass it on later to someone who's
doing data science work so what's next
what's next for this right now that
doesn't seem to be a common consensus
around best practices and this in the
industry I'd love to see that come about
I'd also love to see us learn from unit
testing in software development to find
a way of like before or as you're
writing a system figure out what sorts
of information you expect to come out of
it and have an automated check run that
can alert you if that doesn't happen I
I'm really I know so I met some folks at
strata who are talking about doing that
and so I'm really curious to see where
that goes so thank you very much
I appreciate you coming to this talk